hello and welcome to this video playing
machete and we get the bankroll see it's
an exotic flag machete don't text yes we
all know that the shells okay Jay the NT
six next for some ground plane in the
center yeah this is the main line with a
three I can also take but when I analyze
this are 36 is good however as usual it
has been a while since I looked at it
and I tend to forget stuff so we'll see
what happens 95 Wow okay so we should be
hives what is it really so great okay
I'll take this come on I'll take this
okay so we should be seven probably I
mean night I can also play this I mean
that sets the more dynamic moving away
let's do it i mean i have twin to be six
the temple and the bishop we can also
take this is better here he cannot
cancel because of Queen B 6
and now i'm actually a poor knob ok
quindi six he's got clean a eight that's
not good so I have to go here
the castle it's like a Bishop c5 check
and then I can castle myself and white
has to somehow I know keep things to do
stuff keep me busy and away because like
a thinks run normally black just wins
here so um what to do I wonder if he's
threatening to take on before and maybe
he does I was thinking about 95 a bishop
before takes extreme takes is really a
problem so I maybe have to do stuff like
that
maybe 92 to love the check okay probably
you will play some look see one trying
to check here and 97 cheap old now okay
no do that anyway yep going for cheapos
yeah queen aah i was thinking
if it is not trade queens I might have
night to see seven questioning or asking
a question to the bishop here posing a
question and I'm on that long diagonal
so he has to be a little bit on the
lookout for stuff on Xtreme maybe you
have to trade it's not it's not as fun
move to clay but maybe you have to do it
Jim Queen doesn't really have called
squares I mean III or something don't
doesn't look good sc2 I thought I mean
doesn't look good this one
I don't know not quite sure actually
want to trade to be honest with this but
it's it's difficult to not to do that
927 before I a little bit a little bit
under pressure as well 96 nights you for
this kind of thing and I don't have to
speed up him maybe he can take exactly
now as their solutely six at the end
rupee six Bishop d7 this is part of this
so it's needs this oh I don't have 93 I
was thinking 93 as possible in isn't I
can take this right not dominating this
this piece
97 coming yeah I know but I wonder what
else establish a g6 looks a little bit
uncomfortable I'm wording check oh so we
just trades into this ending which is
probably lost really amazing not sure it
might be a draw but it's very borderline
[Music]
let's see maybe I have to put it on h4
rather check
probably manages to draw this check
check check check check check check no
Jeff Jack Jack Lee ok so we did not
manage to draw it ok have one a tough
game yes I say that I don't like to the
opening line for wine at all I mean it
is theoretically respective of it it
always feels it's so unnatural to me to
never develop and I don't know player 3
and so on but anything okay i mean this
this I don't believe I mean simply 1992
a fire and so on that's probably
something that black hands completely
refuted with good play which I probably
did not mention a managed I took the
center tall the engine wants to take
perform magic find her black just
interested in this so yeah Bishop d7 has
given us better
maybe this is better I mean this time
covering his six this is still extremely
massive and that each would be for
something that I have somehow expected
as she never played now I could castle
twin see several the analysis could be
seven was better analysis now tough to
play with this time situation he took
this now here he spawns a little bit we
quit I was really shocked that he went
into the ending which is extremely
borderline that it might be a draw of it
is something that let him try on forever
and ever and ever and I ultimately
wanted check check check and once I was
like what they are thinkers it will be
difficult when to to hold check yeah but
now it is a complete one true king king
here would have been at least a trial
and I saw it I can do this and win like
that ok guys thanks for watching